Jared Kushner in charge of negotiating
israeli-palestinian peace try saying
that with a straight face laughable to
begin with more laughable after Trump
recognized Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel which is just such a divisive
thing to do that remove the US as an
even possibly unbiased arbiter in that
conflict so even though the concept of
Kushner is a joke he mostly has avoided
that caught on video type of public
embarrassment until now because he's
been a behind-the-scenes guy until few
days ago he went to the Saban forum
which was organized is organized by the
center for Middle East policy he was
interviewed by Haim Saban headlines all
around about how embarrassing and
humiliating Jared Kushner's appearance
there was and I thought to myself it's
probably being exaggerated it's that
clickbait that I keep hearing about on
the Internet no this is a stunning
public dressing-down of not only Kushner
but the entire idea of this team that
Donald Trump has put together to
negotiate israeli-palestinian peace I'm
guessing maybe Kushner felt safe here
Saban is an Israeli telecom billionaire
Kushner maybe had no reason to think
that this would go horribly wrong but it
did and in this first clip you'll notice
that Kushner is starting to get nervous
very hard swallowing you'll notice him
doing going into a talking point point
coma as I like to call it spitting up
talking points like a baby eating solid
food for the first time can't quite get
it out or down here's how Jared Kushner
started going wrong here is that are of
great concern to people you have Iran
and and their their nuclear ambitions
and their and their expansive regional
mischief you have Isis which this
administration has done a really great
job of beating back and and almost
defeating at this oh yeah
you have the ideology you know the
extremism which I think you're now
seeing a lot of leaders in the Muslim
world try to restore must or the
religion to what it's to what it always
has been and to try to eliminate the
ability for people to
to to pervert it in the way they have
and then you have the
israeli-palestinian issue and I think
that if we're going to try and create
more stability in the region as a whole
you have to solve this this this this
issue and so the president sees it as
something that that has to be solved
that he very much wants to be solved
yeah
and it's something that he's personally
put a lot of time into trying to see
happen so Kushner gets to rattle off
about a minute of these rosy delusional
talking points and then haim saban just
crushes him and points out that hey no
one involved in this team put together
by Trump to negotiate
israeli-palestinian peace has any
qualifications to speak of they're
basically clueless and it is a stunning
take down and then haim saban points out
that there's no one who has a clue even
working on this how are you guys even
still allowed to work on this and you'll
hear the crowd start laughing as if the
73 year-old Saban is joking and Saban
makes it clear no no I'm completely
serious here I understand that but to
achieve that the team has in it an
entrepreneur you a real-estate lawyer a
bankruptcy lawyer I don't know how
you've lasted eight months in this
lineup but that's it for another day and
it's impressive that it's still going
there's not a middle east master in this
group so I mean how do you operate with
people who basically you know with all
due respect the bunch of Orthodox Jews
no idea about anything
so what are you guys doing on this so
I'll definitely say it's not a
conventional team but I'll say it again
okay it's a perfectly qualified team in
the wave hi I'm seize it so how was no
no no I was joking oh so we have so when
we were thinking about how to put a team
together the the president and I focused
on who had the right qualifications who
we both trusted and you know we have
David Friedman who's one of the most
brilliant bankruptcy lawyers who it's a
bankrupt situation so yeah yeah we've
got the best bankruptcy lawyer working
on israeli-palestinian peace I think you
can actually see Kushner start to sweat
here and it went on maybe you can find
the entire thing online now if you don't
know Israelis you might actually think
that Saban is joking because there's
this thing about Israeli culture we'll
where you'll hear escalation in voices
like at the grocery store or at a bank
and you'll think an argument is going on
and it's not those are normal
interactions a lot of examples I could
tell you from my last trip to Israel but
then on the other side you'll see
something like this and it seems kind of
sarcastic kind of kind of ribbing joking
and it's not
this is Haim Saban pointing out that
Kushner and everyone on the team is
clueless what an embarrassment to Jared
Kushner I understand now why he's a
behind the scenes guy yeah I watched
some of this and my favorite point the
sticking point for me was when Sivan
asked Kushner what's going to make Trump
able to solve the israeli-palestinian
conflict yeah
and of course Kushner responded by
saying well he won the election and a
lot of people didn't think he could do
that
it's it's that kind of logic that
actually works on a lot of people so
that's actually an interesting point
because it's so absurd as a
qualification but people will hear that
and they'll say hey that's true that
that actually is a pretty good argument
it's not an argument even though many of
these world leaders also won the
elections of their own yeah and we're
not going around praising them what an
embarrassment for Jared Kushner that's
all the time I have for today
no voicemail great bonus show we'll talk
to you tomorrow